hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to west of loathing now
we got done with all the sheriff stuff
and we got done with all the bar stuff
except for Suzy who I don't know how to
please just yet but I believe that now
we can buy a horse or we can figure out
how to learn dickering and I don't know
how you learn dickering but I imagine
it's gonna be a book but I have no idea
either way oh oh I don't have enough ah
this looks like a good horse
who's the most typical horse you've ever
seen anything special about it
can winning oh hey I got another needles
there needle in every haystack afternoon
sir what can I do for you business oh
you know everyday I'm hustling to tell
you the truth that's pretty terrible all
my horses keep running away well except
for this completely ordinary one that's
rough maybe I can help
oh god yes thank you please don't go
fetch them myself except for this injury
I'll give you 300 meat each for finding
them how many are there three here let
me see your map there's pretty much
always run away the same places these
are three little pictures on your map or
hold mine which is where the shovel is I
discovered a new boring Springs boneyard
and thousand snakes Gulch by these
places I think they like environments
that are thematically appropriate here
when you find one feed at some of these
oats that should send it back here a bag
of homing how does that work they're
special pigeon infused oats okay make
sense all right I'll just I'll accept
that as reality
I got another needle don't mind as I
skate off through the poop okay so I now
have locations with which I can go I'm
gonna go to or hole mines first because
I know that there's something behind the
outhouse ah hey he wasn't kidding not
that this would have been a funny thing
to kiss me but I guess I got a shovel so
with this shovel oh there's still some
meat meat or oh that's where they get
all their meat from the meat mine I got
50 B well good for me I feel bad for
just slopping through that meat got a
mug I don't know what's going on over
here but let's go in the mind
hello whew dark and spooky all right the
mechanism is labeled cargo elevator
control a poster on the wall behind
reads blast
in cap storage plungers both kinds and
tools where do you want to send the
cargo elevator well I don't know yet so
I'm gonna leave that alone already I'll
look around a little bit first unrefined
you find a disgusting chunk of meat or
you got unrefined meat nugget great good
this looks dangerous at least there's no
plunger hooked up to it oh that kind of
plunger that's what you're talking about
I guess I'll send it to level one I'm
not in that am i oh oh blasting caps the
period is part of the label that's why
it's inside the quotes like that okay
dang it looks like you're gonna need a
crowbar to prise it one of these crates
open oh okay how about tools then so any
tools to be able to pry it from the
crate and then plungers yeah to do
something about that I pick a lock oh
yeah all right needle ruin but that's
okay because there were two needles in
that haystack
all right got a crowbar it's good so now
all I need to do is turn down this
volume goddamn it but then I need to
open this blasting cap thing got a
blasting cap and then if I get a plunger
I won't blow myself to smitheroons which
is something that I don't want to do in
this mind of meet Matt my meeting the
collection all right I don't know there
was a sign attached to that I guess it
didn't read it can't get past this
rubble will there good put the plunger
up fighting against your instincts for
self-preservation you've hooked up a
plunger and strung at a fair distance
away that doesn't seem fair enough all
right well let's go for this principle
on jerk you forgot to hook up the
blasting cap well a nice stupid once
you've succeeded in putting yourself in
grave danger
is it point Wow go boom that went off
with better than I thought I did oh
hello good meat Oh dig I got a silver
nugget much better than a meat nugget I
guess hello
see the Dark Horse barely approached her
hey girl it's okay I'm a friend
Winnie the horse shines away from you
though in this case it's more like
crippling introverted
away from people oh come on don't be
like that look I brought some oats for
you they're poison nothing in retrospect
I guess that wasn't a very governing
thing to say I'll pat you on the nose
horses like that right your big old
snoot er did you reach out to batter on
the nose the horse ducks and step
further back into the shadows oh come on
how about some oats
here you go yum yum she shadows away
from you warily and makes a surprisingly
good attempt at hiding in her own shadow
come on please please [ __ ] yourself
what'd that cost me to home look they're
fine you take a handful of bag and toss
them in your mouth it'll like the
roughest blandest breakfast cereal
you've ever eaten Phil it's better than
dry cat food don't ask your smile to
show the horse that you're fine and
realize that you've unconsciously turned
around and walked out the door powerful
those looks at you warily if you reenter
with a cheerful wave see perfectly fine
how about some oats
here you go yummy YUM all right how
about a nose bat ah ah doesn't actually
flee now oats where ELISA grudgingly she
eats them then she gestures at something
behind you you turn around to look but
don't see anything when you turn back
she's gone right then well that's a
convenient game mechanic that somehow
made me able to get that horse back to
town well that's one down but also whoo
God that looks weird I'm gonna go back
to town real quick because you'd go to
town because there was a there was a
digging hole over in yonder woohoo
shovel it is nasty well I didn't want to
shovel it okay I got mystic ality from
shuffling poop that makes a whole lot so
whatever
all right we'll forget that averin all
right well I hope it's down to grateful
for what I done did I got another mug
okay
I'll return the mugs later when I
actually have enough to return but now
we need to go to South maybe go in mm
snakes Gulch wasn't the best idea but
here we are ow
if rocks are really shining oh my gosh
auntie Rock Wow hello thanks looks
sleepy but not that sleepy I'll leave it
alone it
well can't leave alone alright let's go
for this the first
oh-ah melee i am whoa
I'm a good snake puncher - I thought I
might be only a cow punching kind of
cowboy but not so wolf punch its Nick
broke the poor sleepy rattlesnake why
did I do that that's so mean
alright water another one I guess it's
not called one snake Gulch alright hey
whoa these jerks are quick I guess he's
not so sleepy no mo oh boy then what a
bunch of stupid I was a couple of tough
ler yeah that's word I know I know I
know
well fam take some of that home with you
when you're dead and you can't go home
because everyone knows that you're dead
what are you intimidated by my
incredibly stupid walk the snake looks
really angry you're gonna need every
trick in the book to beat this one good
at tricks I think I am anyway oh alright
let's see what else we got
what is uh how ok what is a shoot that
don't do nothing beef up ooh I should
probably do that will not end my turn
I'm baby baby and then I'm gonna hit you
good yeah how do you like my beefed up
hitting fists these whalers are a bit
more media than they once were
I got a backpack full of meat and a
single meat nugget you want that in your
face I don't think so
you take it back with you when you die
alright I got screw up and gumption old
cowboy thing doesn't work out you could
always get a job as a snake exterminator
ow
yow horse looks has gone snake Creek eat
for maybe use some other kind of crazy
before right hello hey there boy hand
fell I'm a friend here
it's okay it's cool right be cool don't
freak out on me alright I'm gonna look
him in the eyes you calmly look at the
horse in the eyes one of them is fixed
in a black sea thousand-yard stare
and the other is revolving madly in its
socket like he's trying to escape it in
every direction simultaneously it looks
to be calming down a little now that
it's clear you are actually are
maybe inspectors though that his nose
you carefully and gently Pat the horses
nose he twitches a bit okay a lot but he
seems to recognize that you aren't going
to eat his eyes or suckers soul or
whatever madness is bouncing around in
that skillet is that's a good boy as it
heard Pete emotes you hungry I got a
little treat for you nerve you feed the
crazy horse some Homa notes and it
gallops away with a whinny
a rather a would hear hopefully he's
headed home and not into the 12th
dimension cool
alrighty then well accomplish that
anything else over here ow
I managed to snag on every single one of
those how about the graveyard I'm spooky
our founder Zephaniah boring he's
actually the interesting guy
dirty mug benjamin Crockett well he
showed up will be uh should I dig this
up it's gonna be a fight for regard
skeletons they could do it over there
I'll get to you in a second sir I'll be
right with you don't worry about a thing
I got to fight the Skellington
apparently Oh get VP Oh
alright now I'm gonna give BP I am oh
how you like that how how you dare tag
mum Fleur bumper tink I'll show you what
it needs three hits well it's gonna be a
bit more let's go be a bit more Grievous
than I thought it would BAM my cow punch
knows nipple limits hey I got muscled up
I got an old cavalry saber and I got a
gold tooth that's good can I actually
use that cavalry saber it seems like it
might be better than my brass knuckles
be that they may be grandmas or what
have you
let's see oh yeah that's better
ooh also anything else that I got here I
could I could actually use the the
broken board as a weapon but I'll hold
onto it for just a little bit longer
yeah chunk of mostly worthless rock shot
through with veins of gristle and flicks
and well babe oh is it actually alive is
that is that that whole like mine alive
oh the skeleton you're not kidding past
it without a scuffle why am I not
getting past there without us
shuffle that don't make no sense that
don't make a lick of sense
Moo I'm beefy baby hi oh my god that
saber was worth it and getting beef you
got to be free
oh I'm not really a cowpuncher anymore
I'm more cow slicer tough customer level
what it mean both of these all these
attributes what in the hell is this
ready to your rough-and-tumble rowdy and
ready to rumble intimidating you have a
way of getting what you want that's so
nice look at me look at me with all my
gumption and clicker and grit
oh the alliteration is nice oh it's a
ghost horse your pulse quickens as you
get near the spooky translucent horse
you approach to the weird
semi-transparent horse cautiously so
it's not to startle err so you quickly
come to realization that this is not a
horse that startles easily hello there
I'm a friend okay hey that's a little
change how'd you do that without opening
your mouth well I doubt I could Pat her
on the nose but I'll give it a go
you've had the horse's nose would be
very cold if you were going to Rider you
would want an extra saddle blanket to
keep your butt from reason batter nose
again yep still cold yep still cold yep
nice still cold so cold I got a funny
feeling there's something at the end of
this dream but I don't know if I should
actually [ __ ] die because it seems
pretty stupid I'm very cold
unbelievable are fine Peter deals here
you go hamster modes you hold out a
handful of votes for the horse but she
just sort of scares right through you
burger please don't look at me like that
fatty oats again what's the matter
are they not spooky enough I'm not sure
how to make seok spooky I guess I could
put some bone meal in them but I don't
have anything Andy to grind up bones
with grave dirt we're knee better yes
weird okay that's some grave dirt
sprinkle the else with just a little bit
of grave dirt and hold them out again
the horse games is expressionless ly
happening Tennyson
hey that's weird why is the horse guy
sella ghost horse how's that even gonna
work
Timothy Cochran devoted husband
Elizabeth Cochran beloved daughter silas
Cochran Oh baby
oh no that's sad and why can't I go past
here what can I do anything
ah so well alright fine time to get back
to town I gotta return these um I got
returned all these do bird a pursue
she's that's a death a new one I don't
think I've seen that one before
hey I got a bunch of bar things I got
these mugs 75 god that's not nearly
enough you guys deserve more whatever or
I got your horses back I don't know how
you spotted him hiding in the mind but
thank you for sending back my dark horse
sure thing
it's Michael my pale horse made it back
safe thanks for your help thanks for
finding my crazy horse he was eating
loco weed wasn't he not that I noticed
that's all done I can't thank you enough
here's a little extra for you thank you
afternoon sir what can I do for you you
said something earlier about an injury
yeah I busted my knee walls mucking out
the showroom don't ask how it's
embarrassing I was gonna ask doc Alice
stab a look at it but she gave up dr.
innit
why'd you do that nobody knows he just
shut herself up in her office said she
wouldn't talk to anybody except nursing
whiskey that actual nurse or her sure
she was just being sarcastic see
alrighty then
well where is nurse whiskey I mean
where's nurse nurse nurse
what's the sheriff up to you do anything
chef later all right never mind then
where's his whiskey oh oh I got whiskey
whiskey delivery for you doc what brand
nurse whiskey your favorite I'm led to
believe didn't know she made house calls
all right hold on you're the rattle
issue unlocks door OH
Wyman values me while I slide on the
floor doc Alice looks to be about in her
50s her hair is gray or faces line but
her eyes are still clear and sharp its
bloodshot she holds out her hand whiskey
stat no what the hell I'll let you in
for then a shrug okay nevermind what
well there yeah there shouldn't this be
further away from the fireplace given my
limited experience with whiskey
I mean explosives that seems bad the
stove is bottle is either she's really
compulsive about cleaning or she never
cooks all right well Wow
yeah let's see hey Doc can I give you a
look at your books that sounded weird
but you know I don't know how to word
good
there you go she cracks open the pot of
whiskey and filled a small flash she
takes out of her pocket she then puts
the flats back in her pocket and starts
chugging out of the bottle
geez doc that doesn't seem healthy but
then again I'm not a doctor whose doctor
c'mere you okay point taken
all righty then Callaghan bucks sure if
you want to not that they're gonna do
you much in this dude forsaken hellhole
he's trying to be less cheerful doc you
survey the books on Alice's shell
you got a book on dickering is that a
medical procedure of which I can know
about nurse doc you're a doctor not a
nurse I'm not any of those but dickering
that's the subject of which I want to
know more about I mean I can summarize
what it could mean from the words dick
and urn I know all about those two but
combining them as ludes me all right you
take care of yourself all right legend
of curly Smith this book seems a lot
like dickering who's curly and why is it
me curly life and work of Fred Ferguson
the Goblin oyd tongues a primer oh I
should have read that before I killed
the Goblin shouldn't I have uh well that
would have been nice
oh well let's go Curly's me book tells
the story of a legendary treasure a
massive chest full of premium meat
secret it in the hidden sense not the
extruded sense in the Western Desert by
an old cow handmade curly Butterfield
all right
wait did not kill Curley Butterfield
wasn't that the guy that I killed the
life and works of Fred Ferguson all
right Civil War surgeons autobiography
flipping three mostly find a reason to
drink out and all bad so it's actually a
ludicrous speculative fiction huh at
least there are some useful appendices
in back and some diagrams of appendices
oh oh you start flipping through the
goblin language look it's confusing at
first but ventually get so engrossed by
it that you take time break free reading
several blurps have passed
you also know that blur fizz the goblin
word for our you've learned to speak
goblin sort of all right fine man
yep shut it down that before I killed
that goblin oh well this vanity doesn't
look like it sees much use much cream
excuse me grab the tweezers and pluck
some of your more slightly eyebrows all
right
everything all right it depends on how
fast I can give this whiskey into my
bloodstream compared to how fast my
liver filters it out and I can't talk
and drink at the same time so so uh I
mean what's the matter doc what's the
matter the whole world's gone to hell in
a horse cart you asked what's the matter
and it's cow demons cow demons is that
when the cows came home dead men walking
why don't you go ahead and pick one I'll
drink to that dead men walking
you haven't seen it corpses and
skeletons staggering around like puppets
with half their strings cut looking to
take a bite out of living oh yeah there
was a skeleton in the cemetery it's nice
to get some contact confirmation and I'm
not losing my damn mind how is that even
possible
it is impossible it goes against
everything I know about Medicine dead
patients don't get back up patients oh
I'll show every doctor loses one now and
again you never get used to it but what
happens but what doesn't happen is them
coming back afterwards and looking for
revenge that must be pretty rough rough
buddy I don't think you comprehend the
situation it's not just patients
neighbors friends husbands oh yes okay
um indeed whoa
whoop a little bit if we do would you
just get out of my way out of that
situation and school my butt to relieve
myself of what's going on let's see
you're not allowed in Topeka anymore
remember I only left home not really
that I really anything about that but
hang on let me go back because I want to
confirm there was some treasure about
Wilson Wilson
Beauregard skeleton captain ah maybe not
maybe not all right whatever whoo I'll
go back all right so I don't know if
there's anything else to do besides buy
a horse but let me just double-check on
everything here and then maybe there's
something else now just want to say hi
how's it going Susie Cochran Oh
I saw the graves in the cemetery I'm
sorry for your loss oh I saw it happen
saw the whole damn thing happened and I
couldn't do nothing about it the
bartender said it was cows cows right I
don't know what those things are but
they encounter anymore what happened is
raid nan Paul used to ranch cattle back
before well before they came home Bob
didn't make it come on I managed to
rebuild we ranch pigs instead she left
me the place when she passed gone well I
guess a passing herd sniffed out that it
used to be a cow ran too may attack a
couple days ago happened so fast I
didn't even have time to get my rifle
out of the gun safe cow smashed in the
front door and a fire started out back
by the root cellar I was went up in
blaze just like that what did you do
I there wasn't anything I could do
couldn't get upstairs to the kids coz of
the fire and I saw Tim trampled right in
front of me I just I want to talk about
it she reflows our mugs what will you do
now head west I suppose nothing keeping
me here and no desire to stay I can't
leave without my rifle though why not
it was Mars rifle it's all I got left of
of anybody left it at the ranch like a
damn fool listen can I ask you a favor I
need someone to go get it for me yeah
I'll go get it
of course I will of course I will Susan
Cochran I'll be right back as a
tumbleweed away I'm perfectly capable of
doing this man that's a sad tale Cochran
ranch that's a damn shame
who this thing was burned to ground all
the water in this trough is boiled away
boy yeesh I think my stupid walking is a
bit out of place here oh wow who are you
doing back there
good thing I'm a cowpuncher I'm go
through it anyway woo oh hey buddy here
let me tuck and roll somebody in middle
of fixing a knife I got a varmint
skinning knife is that better than my
knife Calvary's still better
Oh allows you to collect skins from
beasts after combats now that only if I
equip it or is that without the only way
I'll know is if I don't equip it and use
it right these pies were not safe
Oh what the hell are you hey who are you
the thing looks angry you're not gonna
make it to the safe with that feeling
with it I'm gonna deal with it hey
you're not the only one that can be [ __ ]
look at me wow I'm so beefy now you want
to mess with me I got a lot of beef ha
whoa you can't stand up to foul
how do you do that to light me on fire
that seems a little bit unnecessary but
I want anyway so it's good I got glamour
all I'm glamorous oh it's the Cochran's
family gun safe grab Suzy's rifle okay
well I got that let it up build ah this
isn't disrespectful at all the walk
stupidly around here yeah this is the
only thing standing yeah dang it
poof ah - I still hear that you should
be dead so I'm going to cartwheel off to
safety
excuse me all right let's go back Suzi
Suzanne I got your gun doodlee do Hey
you find my rifle yet strange yep your
shoes Susie's eyes well up with tears
you handed the rifle and she roughly
scrubs her sleeve across her face before
any of them spill over thanks stranger I
didn't catch your name
I'm mom Fleur thanks mum Fleur can't
rightly say what this means to me she
looks at the rifle for a long moment
then looks back up at you she sighs well
that's enough wallow in misery time for
me to hit the road if you want me to tag
along with you
you're head west you say the word I'm
good Susie I'm a hands too hectic over
here Phoebe wanted to see if maybe there
was anybody down here like any Goblin
traces left over that I could possibly
scour through is he all right
I don't know when I'm heading west but I
think I can buy meself something what's
with you wait who me oh wait oh I'd be
mining these mountains longer than a
deft left-handed Sandpiper can whistle
Dixie uh-huh okay is either that there's
a rash on a rock he got stranger I'll
give you seven meet for the rock that
doesn't seem like a lot to yourself
notice is the nugget of silver you found
earlier I'll take that old silver nugget
off your hands if you like you
eighty-one before
no thank you you ain't seem like someone
got much used for unrefined or stranger
I'll buy it off here 473 me all righty
then
well what if I what if I changed my mind
I'm gonna change my mind I'm gonna sell
all these did take that thank you take
that thank you take that thank you
he's size narrows as the gears start to
click in his head he fixes his gaze on
you and the tick in his eyelid seems
more pronounced listen kid always
tougher I've been buying from you you've
been spending time underground ain't you
well you listen to old Pete's advice
you'll stay out over holes you know it's
good for you there's stuff down on the
40th level that ain't worth messing with
brother fella once keep his eyes if you
catch my meaning it not sure I do but
I'm about to go down there immediately
now all right well I am literally gonna
go down there all right well let's go to
or hole and find out what's on the xl
level
doodlee doodlee doodlee do hello
let's see suddenly you remember that
weird thing that Pete said about level
40s and a real thing all right what's
the level 40 whew strains black chest
okay a wave of nausea hits you as you
slide a heavy lid off the chest inside
there's a hat it looks evil
not in an abstract way it is eyes and
they look like the eyes of a murderer
and it has teeth which looks like the
teeth of an animal who would be murder
if animals understood the concept of
murder well I think they can adieu but
maybe not in that sense I'm going to put
on the Hat yeah I'm putting on you have
a sense of foreboding something tells
you this is a bad idea it's me I'm
telling you this is a bad idea if you
want to put this hat on you won't ever
be able to take it off and things will
be much harder for you it will be as if
for your life as a game and that games
difficulty level and greatly increased
if you catch my meaning I'm gonna put on
the Hat
bring it on things haven't been that
hard anyway maybe I should maybe I
should ah but I'm just I want a ride oh
such a nice hat baby I'm so confused
ah what do I do I'm gonna put on that
you got a damn hard hat you grab a
terrible hat and put it on your head you
hear a sigh is your coming from above
your forehead if you feel the hats deep
and sink into your skull this is gonna
be great a voice whispers well that's
bad idea we'll hope you like a bunch of
stupid walks ah [ __ ] her too hat go
anyway that might have been a horrible
mistake but I'm gonna live with it now
because I could not resist the idea of
putting on a cursed hat how could I
revoke that curse that did it anyway let
me do what the old man actually says
about it then I'll end the episode there
he's probably gonna be really pissed
but hopefully hilariously see what do
you say Pete oh alright never mind I
don't mind the fact that I got an evil
hat on me so anyway thank you everybody
so much for watching that was probably a
horrendous error but I don't regret it
at least so thanks again everybody for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]